we're gonna jump to this next story I
have to do this one right away because I
owe Neo an apology Neo defends his
opinion clarifies apology after
declaring opposition to Children
undergoing medical gender transition I
need you all to hear this from the
horse's mouth at the publicist's
computer so let's break the story down
we got this from Rolling Stone Neo
apologizes for criticizing parents who
support children deciding their gender
identity
saying gender identity is nuanced and I
can honestly admit that I plan to better
educate myself on the topic so I can
approach future conversations with more
empathy basically he goes on this
podcast and he's like kids can't decide
this stuff I feel like parents don't
know what it means to be parents anymore
if a kid comes and says he wants to eat
candy all day and you let him he'll do
it he says if your five-year-old son
comes says I feel like a girl you're
gonna rock with that he's like these
kids can't make these prominent life
decisions what ends up happening is he
puts out this post on Twitter saying I'd
like to express my deepest apologies
after much reflection I'd like to
express my deepest apologies to anyone
that it may have hurt with my comments
on parenting and gender identity they've
always been an advocate in love oh blah
I understand how my comments could have
been interpreted gender identity is
nuance and I can honestly admit that I
plan to better educate myself on the
topic I can approach blah blah blah I
lead with love and support well
about a video I'm gonna play this video
for you you can hear it straight from
him you guys ready yep what's going on
loved ones this is Neo all right listen
I normally don't give too much of a damn
about what y'all think about what I do
what y'all have to say about what I say
whatever I normally don't care because
like I said opinions ain't special
everybody got one however this is
something I feel very strongly on and I
need y'all to hear this from the horse's
mouth not to publish his computer so
check this out first and foremost I do
not apologize for having an opinion on
this matter I am a 43 year old
heterosexual man raising five boys and
two girls okay that's my reality now if
my opinion offended somebody yeah sure I
apologize for you being offended because
that wasn't my intention my intention is
never to offend anybody however I'm
entitled to feel how I feel I'm
absolutely entitled to feel how I feel
the same way you are entitled to feel
how you feel I ain't asked nobody to
follow me I ain't ask nobody to agree
with me I was asked a question and I
answered the damn question okay I have
no beef with the
lbgtqia plus Community whatsoever I
ain't got no beef with y'all do whatever
the hell it is you want to do do what
you want to do with your kids however
somebody asked my opinion on this matter
and this is how I feel I will never be
okay with allowing a child to make a
decision that detrimental to their life
I will never be okay with that I don't
care I definitely plan to educate myself
a little bit more on this matter however
I doubt that there's any book
somebody's gonna tell me that's gonna
make me okay we're letting the child
make a decision like that that's just
period Point Blank and that's how I feel
if I get canceled for this then you know
what maybe this is a world where they
don't need a Neo no more wow and I got
no problem with that I'm a hustler all
right I'll figure it out I got kids to
raise and I'm gonna do that regardless
so with that being said
y'all have a good day I love everybody
live how you want to live love how you
want to love but your opinion is yours
speak your opinion as much as you damn
well feel like it because as I said
they're not important they're not
special everybody got one and you're
entitled to it I'm entitled to mine all
right y'all feel how y'all want to feel
have a great day it's Neo peace and love
so that that was not not only did he
come out and say no to that apology he
did it in a very very very strong way so
uh
I feel I look I I want to defend myself
a little bit like I had no idea who's
gonna do this of course most of these
celebrities come out and go oh I'm so
sorry oh wow I'm whiny baby this dude
just came out
manly 10 out of 10. like I was saying
you're not a man you're not a father no
no this dude is a real man is a real
father this is what father should be
doing that's what men should be doing he
did it right he was respectful he said
I'm not trying to offend you and I'm
like that's exactly right none of us are
trying to offend people we're trying to
express ourselves but I want to point
out you notice that I would never be
okay with a kid doing something that
detrimental to themselves yeah he's
outright saying it is harm it's not just
a how could you know like how could you
feel the way no he's not right saying
it's bad it's modern lobotomies yeah
literally well I think he's just telling
the truth but what's so what's so
remarkable about it is that in the music
industry in particular you just can't
get away with this like I I tweeted out
a couple hours ago like if you
appreciate this guy this honesty and if
you want to support this man and you
want to see more truth in the world it's
really important we really around this
dude because I think they're going to
come for him yeah I want to know what
happened with this public
ity he's like it's not
it's an army and not
the computer which by the way we have to
note how many
oh and this is my message by the way
it's me Neo like signed off for the same
he's not afraid that this is his opinion
uh I I think it's interesting that there
was a statement released at all and he's
obviously not okay with it I assume his
bubbles is getting fired probably
rightly so but then what was the
conversation behind the scenes were they
like you have to put out a statement
he's like oh yeah let me think about
what I want to say and then I'll comment
on and they were like anyway so we're
posting this which didn't even really it
sounds like every gender identity
educated University bachelor's degree
person I've ever heard he's like oh yes
I will educate myself and this is new
and like it's generic this is obviously
much stronger and much fresher I also
think it's much more relatable to
parents who are like I'm not going to
change my I have a a million children to
raise and I'm not going to waver in this
did he say he's got seven kids yes five
kids five boys two girls I want to
clarify two because I don't know he said
but he's a singer but people have been
calling him a rapper no he's just no
he's a singer yeah
I'm telling you his publicist has access
to his Twitter and that's the problem
yeah was it posted to his Twitter I
don't know look it looks like an
Instagram thing to me but I'm not so up
on that let me let me just say wherever
this shakes out whatever post actually
ultimately ends up being the one of
record for Neo in this in this time
frame it is obvious this is who this guy
is hopefully it's the one where he's
beating up
for changing his stuff
change your password this is the moment
yeah dude like Break Free Break Free
it's it does seem crazy that they I mean
I don't know if that's actually deleted
so I don't want to like propagate false
information but uh I'm sure the internal
publicist who charges him thousands and
thousands of dollars to do their
services is now freaking out because
they're like no we already put out a
party line
the videos on his on his Instagram okay
I just checked all right great yeah
about what I say whatever yeah not only
that but like he's coming after the
media too because they got this one
story where it says Neo condemns parents
allowing children to transition and he's
he responded first and foremost I
condemn no one who might have condemned
anybody your life your kids your choice
I was asked a question I answered it my
opinion is mine I'm not asking anybody
to agree with me nor am I telling you
what you can and cannot do with your
children I said in my opinion on the
matter that's that why should i k why
should I care if my opinion upsets you
when you don't care if yours upsets
anyone opinions aren't special we all
have one people voice them regularly
whether they've asked or not dude that
was based why should I care if my
opinion upsets you when you don't care
if your opinion upsets anyone else yeah
that's exactly
good Lyricist over here that's been true
for you yeah so there you go I'm proud
of him I'll just say it I'm proud of him
yeah I want to buy some Neo Maro chapter
we got to get uh Neo Jersey or whatever
to hang on the wall like yeah yeah Luke
did with Kyrie Irving okay no but I
think there's something to be said about
that I mean why should he have to guard
his opinion based on what random people
on the internet think of him well what's
even listen to his music or you don't
like him don't freak out well what's
even crazier about it is like his
opinion is by all accounts unless you're
a lunatic reasonable he's saying that
children aren't prepared to make these
decisions that's it and then he's going
out of his way to say and I'm also not
condemning them let me take it another
step Neo I am condemning yeah if you're
a parent and you're actually allowing
your kid to make these decisions before
they're of age you're a bad parent
imagine absolutely being like my
five-year-old identifies as a cowboy so
I'm gonna buy him a gun
nah he could he could get hurt he thinks
he's a bird we're going skydiving this
is all like what are we talking about to
be fair with with a proper instructor
skydiving is nowhere near as bad as like
giving a child a gun he's a race car
driver so give him the keys to the car
right right go let him do it there are
tons of terrible decisions parents could
make I just think this one is obviously
one people are questioning and
especially since this is not a minority
opinion Neo is actually among a lot of
people who say this is not something we
should just encourage they shouldn't be
giving to you they shouldn't be giving
uh teenagers plastic surgery of any kind
no yeah I mean yeah I was talking about
this the other day with some friends how
in uh I think in like Arizona it's
really big for teenage girls to get tons
of plastic surgery and I'm like that's
just it's not actually it's not as bad
it's not sterilizing them but it's still
really really bad and it's in a similar
category where we should not be telling
kids these kids are like my nose is bad
so I'm gonna get surgery no no no no no
dude you you know what what's crazy to
me is that we live in this world where
people refuse to be themselves just wait
until you stop growing Bella Hadid came
out very famously and was like I am I
got a nose job when I was like 14 15
something like that and I regret it I my
nose is part of my ancestry I looked
more like my relatives and I am sad that
I did that and you know obviously she's
a successful model like things have been
okay for her but it is interesting that
probably being pushed into a modeling
career they're like you should change
your nose and she was like okay before
she was old enough to understand the
consequences of the decision so yeah you
know it's funny you know that song I
think it's Christina Aguilera I could be
wrong you're beautiful or whatever is it
you're beautiful and then it's like it
shows a whole bunch of goofy ass people
in the music video but it's like you're
beautiful or something like that yes yes
I thought it was funny that that was the
message a while ago where it's like no
matter who you are no matter what what
it is you know you you look like or
where you come from it was blunt
actually it was James Blunt yeah that's
that's tell me there I think uh there's
different there's differences I'm sure
there have been 100 music videos like
this I'm gonna love with you guys
popular thought that's been shared I
mean it's the the marriage I think I'm
right you are beautiful maybe James
Blunt does have one called your beauty I
mean it's a banger there are multiple
songs you are beautiful you are
beautiful and ever it's called Beautiful
by Christina's playlist of media
it's
called you are beautiful and so we used
to have this song
sorry we used to have the song where it
was like no matter what you look like
you're good now it's like surgery awaits
if you're unhappy with your body yeah
okay yeah you're right that I mean
yeah we've uh we've gotten pretty far
away but it's it's it's the same with a
lot of things where it's just not really
accepting human nature or how we are
born or built it's it's dangerous the
trend line is not good I mean look I'm
I'm probably a little more Pro body
modification and stuff than anyone else
sitting at the table but if you're a kid
like this stuff is not for children
because your brain isn't developed like
you gotta you're not your brain isn't
fully developed until you're 25 or
something like that you wanna you wanna
get
surgeries that modify your body do it
when you're an adult you can live your
life as a as the opposite sex if you
want I'm not personally for that stuff
but at least those kind of things aren't
like they're not irreversible and
encouraging people to get serious body
modification before they're even an
adult is they're unconscionable there's
some that's that's like there's a very
degrees right a kid who wants to get
their ears pierced we don't really care
that much about right certain body
modifications like oh whatever like a
nose ring in the side or something yeah
but humans are like okay people want to
kids want to stretch their ears out and
stuff like that and it's like look I
know tons of people with plugs and stuff
but it's like and I used to have like
gauged earrings and stuff you probably
shouldn't be doing that until you're an
adult either because even those need
surgery to get made to repair if you get
them too stretched out even um I was
gonna say just the number of kids who
turn 18 and get tattoos tattoos are more
and more common in in this day and age
which doesn't have to be bad but I bet
we can all name someone whose parents
said they could get a tattoo at you know
17 16 and they look at that tattoo and
they're like oh I regret this this was
dumb of course I mean then imagine it
being your genitalia I'm gonna write a
song song called change your body
because you're ugly and you suck
and it's going to be a parody of these
your beautiful you are beautiful in
every single way and it's going to be
like no one likes you you don't fit in
you don't look like everyone else
therefore surgery awaits in Hollywood
and it goes on the Same album as insulin
resistance but yes and but but think
about this this idea that the people who
claim and to believe in body positivity
are telling people to get surgeries to
look like other people like you don't
actually like their body you're telling
them you're telling them to go change
themselves instead of telling them that
they're fine the way they are
yeah well that used to be the message
it's completely inverted from what it
used to be it used to be like accept
yourself for who you are but this is the
same thing with like the you know the
colorblind movement it was like all
right that was basically the Civil
Rights idea was that we were going to
try and get past our immutable
characteristics and accept each other
for who we are as individuals blah blah
now you're aggressive and a racist if
you feel that way and it's the same
thing with body acceptance It's like
well we used to try and Advocate that
you just accept yourself for who you are
how you were born and now it's okay if
you want to completely change everything
from your DNA on it and it makes sense
why anxiety man yeah it's a crispr is
coming yeah no it is if it's not already
here no I mean people are already doing
genetic modification on themselves it
seems totally crazy I mean this makes
sense why people are so anxious and so
in search of identity because if you're
willing to modify your body to that
degree there's no there's no ceiling on
this you'll be always searching for the
next thrill more acceptance I don't feel
good yet I have to do the next thing I
have to do the next thing after the next
thing it's yes and that's ultimately one
of the things that wears in my Society
like to mentioned before with Megan
Rapinoe you know we don't feel like we
can root for her because she wouldn't
root for us she wouldn't root for the
country I mean if she would actively
root against us right if you don't root
for yourself as you are if you're
constantly seeking validation and things
around you and in physical modification
then how are you ever to be truly happy
I think that there's a lot of I think
there's multiple uh different reasons
people might want to modify their bodies
um and I don't think that it's just
people that are mentally ill or well I
don't think getting gauges in your ears
are the same thing as being like I would
like Top surgery please like very
different yeah but I mean there's
there's also in the future either like
the modifications that are the options
that people have for modifications
they're going to be
significantly more broad very very soon
and people that are going to decide I
want to have you know stronger arms
that's going to be an option people now
they can they can decide they want to
extend their legs nowadays there are
guys that will spend six months laid up
so they can get an extra two or three
inches of height and you know the things
that people will go to or the lengths
that people will go to to change their
bodies
if if people will do that for just a
couple inches of height imagine what
they would do for the ability to see you
know not just see better but have super
human vision and these things are very
close they're not that far away what's
actually you're talking 10 20 years ago
they do this the hackers have been doing
this thing where you sew magnets into
your fingertips and that gives you
Electro I think it's called Electro
sense you put a neodymium magnet under
your skin and sew it up and then what
happens is the slight vibrations from
the electron electromagnetic frequencies
coming from electrical appliances and
cables cause a vibration in the magnet
pressing against the nerves in your hand
you can feel where electricity comes
from so you could literally run your
hand on the wall and then feel where the
the power lines are running see and so
like a MAG like a neodymium magnet is
extremely uh non-invasive right it's not
like putting a machine in your hand but
it still doesn't work it doesn't work
what do you mean it eventually gets
rejected oh yeah it will shatter and
break out of your skin yeah so it
doesn't stay but even still like that's
just obvi like you said that was years
and years and years ago that people
started doing doing that and that's you
know one guy even so home biohacking one
guy even put a full computer in his arm
under his skin like crazy stuff I I
think that the the unintended
consequence of all this body
modification and these like I don't know
hybrid human cyborg type things is that
ultimately I I can only speak for men in
this regard but when we had a shortfall
biologically you know whether it be our
height or whatever attractiveness we
would either become funny or become
musicians you know like we would there
there would be some balance it out yeah
and like if you are able to just like go
to a doctor and pay and then be this
specimen it kind of detracts from that
that other Avenue of becoming a more
impressive human being I don't know
let's remember Elon Musk uh made a lot
of money and then his hairline came back
that's true you know I I think that
there is a relationship between like
being self-aware enough to say like look
this may be and I don't even think like
some of the things we're naming are not
just like actually that big of a deal
like if you're not that tall there are
very short women in the world you're
fine uh the thing is like there are lots
of films
look I'll tell you I tell you what my
life would be extremely different if it
wasn't for the fact that I am a rock
star okay so being a rock star makes up
for at least three or four years you're
reinforcing your series a really good
musician everyone
before he would have never ever even
picked up the guitar
If I Was if I was six four I'd probably
rule the country see told you it's
actually a really good chance you played
basketball maybe yeah real though yeah
like the the taller you get the
percentage chance that you play
basketball gets higher and higher and
higher and there's something like if
you're if you're taller than six six
it's like a 17 chance that you've played
basketball I mean you're like when
you're literally younger high school or
college not like and then something like
if you're at seven feet then there's
like a like a 90 chance yeah like
because they'll they'll just they'll
just hire you like you're tall we don't
care if you're not a player they'll
literally fist fight each other to get
you to sign you know the agents thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time